the coolest character in the movie by
far is dick played by the one and only
Robertson when I first heard the script
I was like is De Niro gonna do this for
real and then when they said yes I was
like okay then I have to be a part of it
somehow to look at him when he's like
offstage and watching you and you're
cracking him up a little bit too and to
see that face I can't deal with huh like
you'll do something I like yeah that's
col de niro face good stuff it's amazing
love them we all grow up watching over
Daryl though I'm standing let's do papa
de Janeiro not saying one word that's
that's gonna be a matzav the wheel I'm
single for that for the first time in 40
years and I want to [ __ ] oh my god I
would break a constant way about cuz the
stuff that would come out of his mouth
was insane well I woke up with a
swastika on my head if it was Italian
beefs wash the castle or swastik at sea
that's plural enough boy is that really
true yeah did you pick these where'd you
where'd you pick that up you pat it up
in your trip state elite there's this
thing Wade says jamba and sticks his
thumb like up my butt you see what what
shabba [ __ ] every time he'd do that i
would i would break one time you forgot
to bend his thumb cuz i like yep really
extra loud I was like Shah dia haha [ __ ]
Shadia it means singer in Arabic and
he's like are you legitimately okay cuz
its handling your hurt and I'm like I'm
fine I'm fine like I'd like walk away
can collect myself